visit expressvpn.com yang and get three
extra months of expressvpn for free
[Music]
i thought it was fascinating that you're
i think the first arab american comedian
to perform for the troops who are
stationed in the middle east so you're
going over there be like hey guys
i was a refugee still i didn't even have
my u.s citizenship
i could have just disappeared in the
middle of night nobody would have cared
it's just like
i straight i didn't have anything any
documentation i like snuck into kuwait
to get him to go to iraq to do it and it
was the first time that i went back
because i felt like i had to reconcile a
lot in my heart about like how fast we
left and
i just thought how incredible it would
be to go perform there and it was
not necessarily it was just like oh i
want to go just perform for the troops
it was more so like if i could perform
in front of them and be myself
and be really my authentic self um then
i could perform anywhere and then i have
no uh no reservations about about doing
shows or being me
you know imagine imagine a scenario
where you're afraid to be yourself
that's how depressing is that or where a
career
coming up is like oh you're palestinian
muslim oh arab oh oh oh oh
why don't you just go by tony and just
be italian like what are you talking
about
i mean it really wore on me for some
years because people were trying to get
me to change
several people that would come out out
of nowhere and or even audience members
or you know
would she's like you're so funny maybe
if you just do this you'll bust out
you know what i mean i'm like oh you
want me to sell my soul great all right
best you want me to erase my grandmother
thank you so much i appreciate it next
you know like
thanks for the advice
[Music]
so uh it's great to reconnect i got to
meet you and your beautiful family
in the magical town of yellow spring
ohio
this summer as part of freaking camp
chapelle
it was amazing i've got a t-shirt
i've got memories i've got there really
is like a summer camp
i ended up i ended up going pretty crazy
there i bought them i bought a
scooter and then three other motorcycles
and so somebody had an accident on my
moped like
they on my motorcycle and they hurt
themselves pretty badly like they
cracked their shoulder and stuff oh wait
wait so that that happened before
i got on michelle's moped and was like
running around yeah so everybody was
looking at you on there like
not not andrew oh that that's why
everyone was scared shitless because i
was like guys
i'm an adult male like this isn't like
uh
you know freaking harley or something
like that's what you might think
that's what you would think next thing
you know parking
parking a scooter can fracture to your
shoulders i still to this day don't know
how he did it but you know
i'm glad he's okay matthew i'm sorry i
love you i hope you're well
yeah shout out to you matthew hope your
shoulders are all right i'm so glad that
at least some people were documenting
parts of
uh the camp experience because i you
know i know that that someone was
working on a
project for it uh and i can see exactly
how you got addicted to buying two
wheeled vehicles there
because it's summer it's beautiful
you're just roaming around
uh and so i see why you didn't stop at
the moped i defend you mo
i defend you and your three motorcycles
uh on top of it
i appreciate i needed that you know i i
was going really smart because i was
like yeah i haven't ridden motorcycles
at least 12 years
so let's get like a 120cc little scoot
situation
put a boom box that's almost bigger than
the entire
scooter itself on the back of it enjoy
these you know
cinematic beautiful gorgeous
you go there like you know you just look
out it's like
americana corn fields like
sunshine it was gorgeous i would pretend
like i'm on american pickers i would
constantly like
stop and she's like oh what is this item
this antique from the 40s it was very
nice like stop at a rusted filled
farm or something like and i would
attempt to buy
some of their junk that's in the yard
that's like one of my favorite pastimes
when i was just trying to decompress it
was so much fun it was so much fun
so how did your wife feel about the
purchases
this is a common question more common
more common than i ever thought
it would be yeah it just like i don't i
didn't really tell her
[Laughter]
i just did it i was very smart about it
though i was like a traditional arab
trader i was like i don't know you know
i was really like checking out the
market what are the pricing honey
i bought the death machine smart i was a
savvy death machine buyer
and then she divorced me you know that's
how that's how this all works out
you know it's a very clear progression
uh you know that that's why they have
that
uh divorce lawyer office attached to the
motorcycle dealing now
[Laughter]
i bet there's a few of them dude this is
a billion dollar business idea that's
why
uh i'm the entrepreneur i've got a
vision
uh you can attach all sorts of mid-life
crises
services to the motorcycle dealership
it's like what you're here buying a bike
would you like
these brand new overpriced sunglasses
that make you look
30 years younger that's how i justify my
purchases
and like sunglasses i have a you know
you can't just buy regular sunglasses or
else you just destroy them throw them
out you won't respect them
you have to buy something of value that
you have to care for them
especially if they have like resale
value as well like oh no i can't lose
these
where are these it makes you way more
conscious of them well
i think to me there's like a threshold
where something becomes real and
uh it's reality often is commensurate to
whatever you paid for it
you know it's like if you buy like five
dollar sunglasses they're not real you
can like lose them sit on them
without no one cares but that as soon as
you break through a certain
investment threshold uh then all of a
sudden it's like okay this is an actual
item of mine that i associate with
myself
and it says something about me and i
take pride in or whatever it is
what is that threshold for me when does
something become real
when does it become real like if it
doesn't exist
otherwise it's like bad this is garbage
so uh so i'm in atlanta georgia i don't
know if you like i'm
campaigning for the special senate
candidate bits
and i was uh getting some food for my
family's on those curbside pick up
things and so i stopped to park the car
there's an automated reader uh and i was
like i don't know how long it's gonna
take me to pick up this food
so i stick the credit card in the reader
and i'm just jamming in like ad time ad
time ad time because like i was like i
don't i don't want to
calculate like like the like the
25 cent per eight minute threshold i
don't want to like cut it that close
because like
who knows how long that like some of
these these places take
so like that that parking experience was
like below my reality threshold i was
just like
like let's just make it so that i'm i'm
not gonna have to deal with this for a
minute it's one reason i became so
passionate about universal basic income
i mean there are a lot of reasons but
uh just like we're now such a society of
folks who are making that
time money trade-off all of the time uh
and
i still do it obviously um though now
the threshold has to be higher for me to
say like okay it's
going to be worth my cycles to try and
save that quarter or whatever it is
[Music]
it's the holidays it's time to reach out
to all those people that you haven't
thought about all year
bust out that bust out that holiday list
say wait a minute
what's your address i'm actually getting
a lot of messages saying what's your
address which i appreciate thank you
everyone i should not make light of this
and then after you get all of these
beautiful cards with that one photo of
you and your family you're proud of
what do you need some stamps it's time
to mail that stuff
and do you really want to go to the post
office and figure it all out when you
can
be 21st century smart and use stamps.com
it brings the us postal service and ups
right to your computer any letter any
package any class of mail if you're not
sending cards and you're
sending a giant boombox as a gift
you can do that too it doesn't matter
they'll even send you a freaking free
scale
if you sign up for stamps.com so don't
spend a minute at the post office this
year who would want to go to the post
office
during a pandemic that would be unwise
during the holidays
during the holidays truly unwise so
there's no risk
with my promo code yang you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus
free postage and a digital scale is it
big enough for you to weigh yourself
on it there's only one way to find out
and that's to actually get it
no long term commitments or contracts
it's actually not you can't weigh a
human on it
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in yang
that stamps.com enter yang stamps.com
never go to the post office again hey
andrew what are what are you and evelyn
getting me for christmas
you gave me something that you're gonna
use you can put stamps on
uh you know i'm i'm getting uh i'm i'm
giving you the
greatest gift of all zach in that zoom
companion your time
you can't put a stamp on that
[Laughter]
you but you could put a stamps.com ad on
that yes you can so stamps.com
enter yang and pour one out for zach's
uh ego here is he's clearly not getting
a present from the yanks for christmas
um and if i'm not getting president i
don't know i don't know who is andrew i
give up all right love you guys
stamps.com
enter yang
[Music]
when i was a kid growing up the child of
immigrants in this country like a
quarter
was precious and i would go to the
arcade and then play it
and then just try and win for as long as
possible it's like that you had to like
stretch the value of that quarter to a
point where
uh you know like you could entertain
yourself all day
ideally that street fighter game at the
corner store
before high school or after high school
was like the one
you know that's that's the game if you
could just make that quarter keep
that that was it that that was like our
test
of value as like a teenager it's like if
you can win
and then it became not only can you win
but can you win with an obscure
character
it's like it's not enough to be good at
view or guile
and defend your quarter but then
eventually when you're like i'm just
gonna screw around i'm just gonna choose
blanca
never choose [ __ ]
oh my god never knew how to play with
that guy
and then there'd be like this ooh from
like the people being like he's choosing
blanca it's like it's like a real
expression of of like confidence or
cockiness
the ultimate cockiness was da halseem
which is now that i reflect on it a
somewhat racist portrayal of like a
hindu warrior whose limb stretches
i love how you just just like sat there
for a second now that i think about it
just like
maybe it was a racist portrayal of just
seeing this
kid like i saw the kid in you like now
that i think about it maybe
maybe i shouldn't have played with that
character well he was also awful as a
character
you know like he was like the sure the
closest thing to a sure loss
was if you played with that guy it could
be that mo
and i are somewhat dating ourselves it
seems like you and i came of age around
the same time but i feel like even the
kids know street fighter i hope it's
eternal i hope it's one of those things
i saw my nephews playing street fighter
in mortal kombat
just over thanksgiving nice yes
but it was like wow oh this is the
mortal kombat y'all are growing up with
that's pretty cool
is it much better than ours it's so much
better the graphics are insane arguable
though
it depends i actually like the classic i
mean
just seeing what they're dealing with i
mean seeing the graphics i kind of miss
the
the dodgy graphics and the you know and
and seeing the pit of death you know
like it's a little bit different a
little bit more group
like really gruesome actually i am
definitely old enough now where i look
back on certain things as like the
standard
of the golden years you know what i mean
like that like
um 90s video games uh
80s and 90s music like it comes on i'm
like oh it doesn't mate no they don't
make this like they used to
you reminded me of a joke uh uh an
amazing comedian
uh jack mayberry he's like you ever ride
around uh
uh with somebody old that always tell
you where things didn't used to be
you know you just be sitting there going
see that there it wasn't there all the
way from there all the way to the wall
over there that wasn't there either hey
look at that that wasn't there that
wasn't there from all the way from there
to all the way to whoa
there it wasn't there hell it was it was
just dark there's nothing out here you
know
so that's what you reminded me of right
now that's actually a reasonable
summation of what's gone wrong with the
country
which is that it really is hey we need
to change things versus
no let's stay the same uh like
have the same rules for ever and then we
don't really have the capacity to
actually change some of these
institutions
explain that for a week a lot of people
are upset over the fact that
the electoral college and the popular
vote aren't lining up
terribly well um so you have folks who
want to get rid of the electoral college
uh but in order to get rid of the
electoral college you
need a super majority of states to get
on board with that and like there's zero
chance that kansas and nebraska are
going to be like you're right
like we shouldn't have this much say so
it's one of those things we look and be
like look this is not changing in the
way that uh some people are arguing
in any realistic fashion as long as you
have um that standard
there are a lot of things that right now
we're having a trouble we're having
trouble
shifting because there's really no
consensus or no
governing majority and it's something
that
makes me very sad it's why i'm in
georgia honestly
is that i hoped that we would have a
government
that could actually address some of the
big problems
coming into 2021 because we've got major
problems
and instead it looks like we're going to
struggle with a degree of
gridlock and dysfunction for the
foreseeable
and and so you have this framework
that's set up that
that says what you can do and you can't
change it unless you had let's let's
call it a super majority let's call it
60 senators or whatever it is in the
current rules
uh and and so the frustration is setting
in
on both sides we're having increasingly
incoherent conversations about it
uh and it makes me very sad it makes me
very sad too like i i told you in the
beginning of
this conversation i mean you were the
first campaign that i ever
vote i mean like not only did i want to
vote for you but i contributed to
oh thank you yes i'm telling you man
look as a as
as a as a as an arab american as a
palestinian background specifically and
also
like sees through has seen so much
[ __ ] throughout my lifetime
um and seen what my family has gone
through my parents have gone through and
seeing
you know global politics
middle eastern politics european pod
just traveling the world
and just and just like you you just
you were so logical about everything
everything that you said i was like yeah
we should move inland
yes we we all we are why are we still
on the coast waiting to drown i don't
know why we're doing this
we should definitely move inland
everybody should you know
get paid for the data that they keep
sucking from us these corporations keep
sucking from
yes that makes perfect sense of course
they don't want you to win you know like
that's how i feel oh you
you're you're want to help people
actually you actually
want to cancel poverty cancel poverty
yes
i knew that's what the shirt said
because i'm a fan like i'm a real fan
and all my friends i grew up with are
all fans like
i grew up in a neighborhood in a leaf uh
which i revere
you know and and that's the that's the
that's the place that raised me man
that's like i love that place so much
it's such a diverse community there i
mean my friends that i grew up with
sargon is half wide half iraqi vinnie
is italian background who's uh
who's uh a flight director at nasa like
absolutely killing it sargon's killing
it uh
guillermo uh who's you know uh half he's
argentinian excuse me
um and having john who's also
argentinian and
and nick who's half iranian half white
and and neil
who comes from indian background and
akash comes from indian back these these
are my brothers that i grew up with and
we all talk about you
oh wow well thank them for me look at
that i got to meet these guys
in our mindset it's like man you're the
guy you're like you make the most sense
everything you say is so logical
everything is just
fixes and resolves these issues like and
we all know i was like this is
they're not going to let them there's
like no way it's just too easy and i'm
sorry to say like that's how i
that's how i think there are millions of
americans who thought the exact same way
and it turns out they were onto
something yeah and then the pandemic had
was like let's just send everybody money
it's like a word is that what we're
gonna do
we're so broke guys we're 20 trillion
minus but uh
whenever we need it because i don't i
don't
i think the pri i think like the stock
market is not real like i still to this
day i haven't had anybody like truly
explain it to me where i walk away and i
feel like oh that makes sense you know
this all really
like no matter what and i know guys in
investment banking and like in
high up positions at the in uh
in new york and in these major banks and
whatnot and i always walk away like
he just really knows he just really
believes this [ __ ]
it's just like you have a brilliant
routine on this
that i saw in uh ohio uh
and i still have your t-shirt that i
wear very proudly where
it has like the the ponzi like the e
pluribus udub
uh as ponzi and uh your riff on it was
genius
uh you know like i was watching it
happen and
thought i haven't seen anything like
this before uh
and it's awesome uh you know i imagine
it may end up being part of
your next special or your next piece of
work yeah hopefully
yeah it will
okay we've all been doing a lot of
netflixing uh and one thing that i have
never have no idea how to keep track of
really is that apparently like
international netflix has all this stuff
that um american netflix and then it all
just kind of moves around
it's like the content like hopscotch is
everywhere
so like die hard will be on netflix one
day and then now
apparently it's only on south korean
netflix and so if you've got a hankering
for
content that you're not seeing right now
on your netflix
one kind of hip way to get there is to
use a vpn and just beam into the
internet like you're someplace else and
you get to keep your data safe no one
can see what you're doing
it's the approach that companies use to
protect employees privacy
and doesn't your privacy matter too so
expressvpn
not only can secure your data make it so
that your data is not getting sold and
resold but it can also give you access
to
all the content in the world because you
can beam in and sign in to these
services
from anywhere if that sounds interesting
to you for the holidays if you just
can't get enough
of some of the holiday movies that
you've been missing out on maybe you
miss i mean diehard's a holiday movie am
i right am i right
you go to expressvpn.com yang get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
watch what you want get your holiday fix
at expressvpn.com
[Music]
so are you i'm just gonna guess um like
are you in texas right now
yeah no i am i'm from houston so i was
uh you know i'm i'm
you know we haven't gone public with
this stuff but i i i'm writing a tv show
currently i'll just be
i'll just be really vague i'm writing a
tv show right now
uh well i yeah i was in a full-blown
writing room and
it was just exhausted so dave invited me
to ohio to do these shows and was like
hey man
you know i've just i was going from my
bedroom to my office and
the absolute mind [ __ ] of writing a show
is
on top of a pandemic civil unrest you
know of course with big
floyd and then brianna and then
everything that was going on globally
and then
aliens are real nobody wants to talk
about that just like
brushed over like there's nothing yeah
aliens are real let's go back to
pandemic i was totally going to share
the reality of aliens as
your president uh i was i i constantly
try to get vinnie to admit it like hey
man you're a flight director now so you
must know some [ __ ] come on
tell us he's like i don't know anything
i don't know anything it was like but
you know like things like that so i was
just i was uh so dave invited me to go
out there and then after the shows were
finished
i came back to houston and or texas and
i just love it here man this is
always be my home i think i think that a
lot of
celebrities that end up making it and
doing well for themselves
some reason just gravitate to want to be
in new york all the time or la all the
time
and i think there's nothing better you
know i'm more of like the dave model
he is that model for like keeping your
your sanity honestly like just going
doing your job going on tour getting the
deals
and then going to a place where excuse
me it keeps you grounded
and it keeps you in touch with that
reality the the people that really care
about you and been there for you and and
you get to share it with them
that's really more valuable than
anything else to me so i've
been very conscious of that that
whenever i get the opportunity to do
things on a really
large scale like i'm doing now um is
just like
the more important it is for me to
highlight a leaf
and to show how special this
neighborhood i mean 80 different
languages spoken
in this language i mean in the in this
neighborhood it's pretty incredible
it's one of the most diverse places i've
ever been on earth
no joke like i'm not just saying that
it's just um
it's just a great spot so it's a great
place and a great place to raise your
kids and be around and
there's something in the water there
like lizzo came out of there and
beyonce came out of there and rashard
lewis and all these like i think megan
the stallion like all these
the great artist toby newegu who's
really popping off right now
yeah toby was there in in ohio he's such
a family guy he brought his two kids
and his and uh lanell has two kids and
then he brought his friends and their
kids they had like third they had seven
children in this
man oh i remember it was freaking kid
fest
i hadn't had an experience like um
ohio in years where i was just like a
human being
walking around uh you know we'd all been
tested so there was like
like you didn't have to mask up in
socially distance you could just have a
normal conversation
uh and uh i
loved it i mean you know like i was
there for dave's birthday and it it
felt like i was getting the gift
honestly i mean that's the beauty of
dave is that like you know it's like
uh like we all get more than we give you
know if he says that it's like hey come
on out it's like a gift to us
uh but just standing there like a human
being having like toby and like coming
with his kids and like holding them and
playing with them and just like hanging
out at dunnells and eating his food
and being like a normal human was uh
beautiful
it's like a beautiful experience that i
hadn't had in
you know certainly months probably years
it's so weird you step out of it and the
world's like
you step back in it's quiet like oh how
he did it was was really impressive i
mean he set the standard
it's kind of sad that a stand-up
comedian can show you how it's done
and and the entire government's like we
don't know
like i don't just stay home
i don't know like it's always like maybe
two weeks
two hours okay seven months like what
the uh deficiencies around treatment
treating the pandemic we had a window of
time where i think you could have had
a consistent message and done some good
um but you know i i think that
people at this point seven eight months
in like it's a lot harder to get
everyone on board with something
uh and we just didn't have the
uh people in place when i say people i
mean like the
human beings the staffers who would
literally meet with you
when you got off the plane uh or would
uh
trace any contacts you had if you did
wind up um interacting with someone
we went and did shows in dubai at the
end of october
dubai comedy festival 50 capacity
they're like
at least getting it back up again
amazing show
at the dubai opera it was it was a you
know it was a
like a breath of fresh air um
to just go and actually feel like things
are
normal um and so when we had to have a
test
before you get into dubai within a
certain period of time
you have to have a negative covet test
you hand them the covet test you go in
you get you know temperature checked and
they go through they ask you some
questions about
you know pandemic questions and you go
through them no no no
okay good give me your test bam you're
over you go to the hotel they ask you
the thing again they check your
temperature everything is very diligent
they created jobs for things that you
didn't think you needed
like you know making sure they clean up
after you immediately at any table
you're at or
you know if you're if you're at the
lounge they created a job for somebody
to just hand you food like that's what
their job is now they're always messed
up
they're the only person handling
everything everything that you can think
of that would be required and things you
never thought you'd think of
they did it at malls there's partitions
everywhere plastic partitions there
i mean it's so detail oriented
everything
right coming back to the states we all
got covert tested we're like hey
we need to give you a cover test they're
like oh no you're fine i was like what
do you mean
we're fine they're like you don't need
one coming back to america i'm like what
do you mean you don't need one
going back to america they're like where
you flying to it's like we're flying
into chicago
and they go oh only boston requires you
to have a cove like what
excuse me like okay well at least we did
it you know at least we just were
responsible enough just to do it
you know and take the time out and pay
for such a test
so anyway we got it done we land i have
global entry
so you don't even have to see anybody
you just scan your passport it
prints out your your receipt and you
leave well i'm massed up i'm like
my picture is just like this you can't
you can't i'm wearing glasses you can't
even see it's me
nobody even checked and and nobody even
checked to see if
much less my temperature nobody checked
my temperature nobody i'd like
properly identified me it could have
been my sister and during
my passport there's a reason why other
countries won't take americans going
that direction
but this direction it's like yeah
whatever like at this point
it's like you can't be bringing it in
and be making it worse at this point
like really like the rest of the world
is trying to contain us
it's mind-blowing we went into the
lounge in chicago
uh no temperature checks uh the buffets
touch everything you want so it's not
like designated to hand you [ __ ]
the tables didn't look like i mean like
they were they were okay
they didn't look like somebody they had
a sheen to it like somebody just cleaned
it
we got up and then they just grab the
stuff and throw it out they're not being
sprayed down
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
it was a com it was night and day in the
truest sense it was night and day
you felt so safe being in dubai you felt
like they really truly had under control
they had mass laws in place where if you
weren't wearing a mask did you say mask
laws
yeah they did they had mass laws in
place like hey if you don't wear
if you don't wear a mask after like a
warning you're gonna get ticketed
if you don't you know if you get covered
dude in america you know this because
you're from texas
if you did that like uh a gunfight would
ensue shortly thereafter
but would they be wearing masks during
that gunfight that's all that matters
[Music]
[Applause]
you remember the beginning of the
pandemic uh when we were all like
what's this deal with toilet paper
what do i have to do why do i have to
stock up on it
well one innovation that has hit the
market during this time
actually alleviates the need to cut
toilet paper by 80
what is this magical device it's
something that some of you have been
abroad
know all about it's a bidet but now
because
we're modern you don't need to buy a new
appliance you can
just have a bidet attachment that you
can attach to an existing toilet
no electricity nothing and then
you can skip the toilet paper oh my gosh
you can become
environmentally friendly modern
international sophisticated
you can start using a french accent or
whatever you want
this thing must be french in its origin
because it's called a bidet
am i right am i right so if this sounds
like something that you'd be into
you should check out hellotushy.com
and you can get ten percent off plus
free shipping right now
at hellotushi.comyang that's
hellotushy.com for 10 off
and free shipping i got a thank you note
about this product the other day made me
happy hello tushy.com
yang they literally have a 60-day
risk-free
happy butt guarantee and a 12-month
warranty so you can literally use this
thing
in your toilet and return it that's
how low-risk this is and i promise
you'll like because i've loved it it's
also cut down space i have a small
apartment
and so i like actually one toilet paper
like package
takes up a ton of room so this doesn't
it's fantastic hellotushy.com
[Music]
i saw a lot of people already getting
vaccinated in the emirates as well
which really blew me away uh some
friends of mine that are online like i
saw habib
uh the great mma fighter getting vaccine
i'm like yo you
are you they're killing it over there
already and by the way i'm not a big
vaccine guy like i'm always suspicious
i all i needed to do was like read one
article in the 90s
about people that were getting vaccines
in africa that
were injected with hiv virus i'm like
okay i'm never i'm never gonna get a
vaccine ever again like i'm never
i'm never gonna do it uh so you go there
and
um and and the experience you have is a
little bit like what
i think my parents are experiencing so
my mom was here
we said you should probably leave the
country because it's probably safer
someplace else because you know she's in
her 70s
and so she's in taiwan and things are
perfectly normal there they had
something like 10 cases like in the
beginning and then that was that was a
wrap
uh and if if you go there because it's
an island you know they can manage it
uh and uh they did manage it
uh and so there's like a very very high
degree of uh cohesion
and public trust uh and now we're a
little bit envious we're like well we
sent her away for her safety and now
she's just you know like hanging out
the rest of it we're like what the heck
is going on here
maybe we should have gone there for our
safety i'm headed to taiwan
mama here i go i just show up who the
hell is this
burly arab guy my mom's actually very
sweet we
we actually did we used to send send her
my friends
and she was always fantastic it was one
of those situations where if you're
going to taiwan
i'd be like hey like uh you know my mom
will take care of you and then i'm like
hey mom i'm afraid coming and then my
mom would show up and be very sweet and
uh
they would fall in love with her and and
whatnot so i grew up as i told you i
grew up in a salad bowl
of many ethnic backgrounds like and and
i can relate to it
and somebody who has tons of family back
home that's the thing like you know
i always tell them hey man if you're
going there i got you just let me know
and they always take care of them you
know like it's like it's a it's a
it's a trust you know it's like this
trust between us
that it's like oh we have when you have
a visitor
it's it's a big deal it's a big deal to
us within our culture and
even our religion and islam like it's a
big big deal like
if if any muslim for instance like just
shows up and like take care of me from
out of town
you're obligated to do it for three days
like you can just do that that's an
awesome rule
so it's like it's just culturally
ingrained in us it's not something that
we have to like try
to do we actually love it and then we
fight over
how much you can take care of this get
like we will just you know i mean like
we'll feed you to death
we will take care of you we'll show you
the side just like part it's just part
of
who we are i do want to revisit um what
you said about vaccines
for a sec i i think that we're going to
need to have this covid
vaccine widely distributed and
administered um because if you wind up
with like a hodgepodge
it's it's never ending really like
there has to be a point and sure they're
going to be a lot of people that have
reservations and skepticism and don't
want to be the first person in the rest
of it
look i'll do it i just need to see a few
people how they work out you know
i think they're going to be a lot of
people with that attitude um and so
but so someone asked me um whether i'd
be
one of the first to get it and i said
yes because i know that if i get it
other people will trust it more
and i'd feel i'd feel uh
happy to do that you know like i i think
that the the kovid
vaccine uh
i don't see uh the risk
outweighing the reward in virtually any
scenario uh you know what i mean like
uh like i think that if you get this
vaccine you'll probably feel shitty for
a few days
and then that'll be that
[Laughter]
look andrew you take it specifically
because to me
you're the guy i trust the most on that
side
i really do man i just like have a lot
of trust in you like just everything you
say like i said before
and i i'd be happy for you to be my lab
rat i
andrew yang willing lab rat
inject this shoulder not the throwing
shoulder
i mean it means a lot to hear you say
that mo i mean that's one reason why i
would do it
i'm telling you i would never i've nev i
would never
contribute to any like i always saw
through the [ __ ] i never
you know i don't like to contribute to
any political thing i just like
even if i sniff a little something i'm
like no you know this is [ __ ] i
contribute to you so i i would
completely trust
if you took the vaccine and
uh i would be like yo is it you good i
would call you a couple days later
how are you feeling bro you feel right
buddy uh how's the temperature
is it working out can you still walk any
pain and then there'd be like a robot
voice i mean being like yes
i feel great i feel wonderful thank you
andrew oh no
i think there are some of these things
where uh you could use more data like if
you
get more data that would be very
beneficial but if the data is
sound and folks i trust uh you know who
are
scientists are on board then uh you know
like i'm on board
and that the the tough truth of it is
that the
mistrust in the united states is sky
high
at this point i there was one point when
i was trying to figure out i was like
who are the most trusted figures in
american life
like who if they were like i'll do this
thing that i was like okay that's cool
and so i tried to make this list i
certainly think dave's on that list
uh um i you know i'm gonna throw out tom
hanks and oprah
uh for fun i don't trust oprah i trust
tom i trust hanks
all right you know you can't get them
all i can't no
tom's on my list michelle obama i think
would be on a lot of people's list
all right don't comment for mo on that
one
moving on i'm taking michelle over obama
i know it's [ __ ] up to say but i would
i would take michelle over i trust i
search michelle more than i do
dude we should do this as like a number
one draft pick like an nba
fantasy draft or like the trust draft
it's like
my most trusted human being in american
life
like number one draft pick dave
chappelle and everyone's like yeah
[Laughter]
i trust dave big time because he's
really skeptical of everything just like
i am so i really trust him on that
so if he's doing something i'm like yo i
think he's vetted this for real
and then i would i trust jon stewart
you're on my list
wow put you three on the list no no
particular order
michelle is interesting i didn't think
about michelle obama
i'd put obama michelle obama on the list
too
uh who's my fifth i wouldn't put tom
hanks on my fifth i mean i love tom
hanks
it's funny like i don't usually trust
toms but tom
hanks is the only time i would trust uh
i don't know who the fifth would be i'm
gonna throw some folks out there that
would be more institutional
more kind of the folks that like a
newspaper would be like oh we should uh
trust this person
actually even if the government were to
come together this is a really
interesting exercise no let's think this
about this all right
so you're the united states of america
and you're like okay we've got this
covid vaccine and we have to have people
like
and trust it you know so we need to
stick some folks
and then have them be like it's cool so
then if you are
the united states government and you're
trying to figure out who you can
ask whether they'll get on board with
this someone just popped into my mind
lebron james that would be like a very
big deal
i would get hank williams on there hank
williams jr to make sure that i get
everybody in the middle i mean
so here were the establishment figures
that i originally thought of that um
i'm just going to throw out there
because i thought of them whatever bill
gates
warren buffett no no
immediately they're too rich i'm a tough
one to crack bro i'm like not i don't
just go with nah
[Music]
one side effect of running for president
is that you become a mattress
connoisseur
because we slept in airbnbs we slept in
cheap hotels we slept in nicer hotels
down the stretch thank you yangyang
and i'd say i consider myself someone
who like doesn't care that much
about a lot of things but i started to
really appreciate it if there was like a
good mattress a foot i became a little
bit of a mattress knob
and now that we're off the trail i only
sleep
on a bed of 10 mattresses piled high on
top of each other
and then if you put a p underneath i can
feel it because i'm a princess now
but if you're in the market for a great
mattress go to helixsleep.com they give
you one of those
quizzes where they personalize the
mattress to you
how you sleep it's the number one best
overall mattress pick
of 2019 and 2020 by gqn wired this is it
this is the best of breed mattress that
they send to you
give you that two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you with a mattress that
will be the best sleep of your life
10-year warranty
100 night risk free that's a little
weird to try a mattress for 100 nights
and then be like now i don't like it
but go to helixsleep.com yang
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com yang that's helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com yang
for up to 200 off
[Music]
if you were to say to the population
being like hey we want you to
get vaccinated one thing that stands to
reason is you'd want people who are
at least tending toward the at-risk
category to get vaccinated because
they're the
highest danger of you know having
serious complications
and so you would probably ask all the
senators hey like
you up for this and then the senator is
going to look up and being like yes i am
or no i'm not
and i i dare say that that would
probably fall somewhat along party lines
unfortunately i'm just guessing
if i saw all the senators get the
vaccine and i saw everybody incoming
like
live feed c-span everyone's i gotta have
and i gotta have somebody i trust on the
inside they're sitting there like
like you're sitting there like i confirm
that this is in fact the vaccine
they don't they don't have like a latex
like sleeve where they're getting like
you know like like i like touch the
flesh and i'm like
it's going into it's not a fake needle
that's just like disappearing when you
put it in there
no no i want to see all this hot that's
how i am though man i need this
and i feel like a lot of americans feel
this way too a lot a lot of americans
will
totally how how sad is that that this is
the
we're the united states of america
the number one supposedly
on earth in everything that for people
that's that's what everybody feels like
even though we're like
we're number 28
we're number 28 if you have like if you
combine our
um social measurements and well-being
around things like
infant mortality clean water public
education
oh public education is the most
disgusting thing i remember just like
leaving when we fled the war in kuwait
in 90 and ended up in houston and i was
going to
private school there and ended up in
public school here and fourth grade was
still like
two plus two equals four
apples yay i'm looking around
you know i was learning already multiple
languages
in elementary and
basically almost doing pre-algebra in
fourth grade
to come into the states i was like what
is this
oh i don't even have to study this is
ever like i never brought a book home
i never ever my mom's like how did you
graduate i was like ma it's a joke
the whole thing is a giant joke you just
have to like
memorize certain pages and then
regurgitate them on test day and you're
fine
and i failed ninth grade like i skipped
and caught up in no time
i had a ball i lived like ferris
bueller's day off all of ninth grade i
just
my father passed away and i just quit on
everything i was going to baseball games
you know i was just i was doing
everything i was going to places i
shouldn't be going i was sneaking into
casinos in louisiana i was just having a
ball
uh and then i later discovered that will
take me nowhere really fast
so then i readjusted one of my teachers
changed my life and got me to do stand
up in class
because that's what i always wanted to
do and and i've been doing stand-up ever
since i was 14 since then but
anyway the point is the education system
is
just a joke thank goodness for that
teacher i mean that story where she said
look i'll let you
pass if you stand up and do stand up for
the class
how many teachers would have done that
so
let's thank that teacher miss reed i've
tried to reach out to her so many times
i can't find her i'm trying to she
doesn't she doesn't open she hasn't
opened her facebook since 2015 or
something
she's not on twitter come on miss reed i
mean she changed your life she probably
changed other people's lives too i mean
any teacher who'd let the let a kid
actually take class time to practice
their comedy and then give them a
passing grade
oh and then she and then she like
literally took me to after i did several
several uh sets in her class over a few
weeks she took me over to theater arts
department and she was like this kid's
been coming in doing original content
and doing all these different accents
and stuff i think he uh
i think he belongs here and then next
thing you know i was in theater and uh
you know getting lead roles in musical
plays
and musical theater and and just getting
lead roles all the way around making uil
i ended up getting a partial scholarship
to go to the nyu school film and
television
uh i didn't take it i stayed i stayed i
had to stay home and take care of the
family
help contribute and work and uh and do
stand-up and i was like i'm gonna be a
comedian anyway so i'm doing stand-up
anyway why do i need to
go do that which i never none of my
family even knew i had that i didn't
tell anybody because i was afraid that
anybody would encourage me to go
and i knew that that would uh that
wouldn't be good for my mom
and my brother i was like i had to stay
behind wow
that's like a freaking movie plot being
like you know
they didn't know that he had the
scholarship in his back pocket
you are a very very dramatic example mo
but studies have shown that arts
education
uh and theater are some of the best
things
for kids long-term success in life and
academic
performance even and it's terrible that
if
a school budget gets tight a lot of the
time that's like the first
stuff they cut because they're like oh
this stuff's a luxury
but it turns out that those are
difference makers for kids in a way that
a lot of the other stuff
um is not so uh
so your teacher was onto something uh
and thank goodness that there
that she was there and that there was a
theater program for you
because those theater programs you know
i'm going to out someone
if you're a part of the yang gang you
know zach grauman my
campaign manager the tall handsome
blonde dude who
um helped make everything happen and he
was like a music theater
geek at a certain point he was like one
of those
like kind of uh um stars the high school
play kind of thing
um like like that that stuff really
makes a big difference
like i think that you end up with like a
very different sense of yourself
and confidence and ability to get up and
express
ideas uh not that everyone can become a
world famous comedian like you are
you know i mean because you know but uh
like someone like zack who has done
great things in his career he started a
non-profit he's done like all sorts of
stuff
uh i i genuinely think that drama
theater and the arts at a young age
are are part of the secret sauce no i
agree i couldn't
i couldn't i'm telling you it saved my
life it really did
not only did it like um
shaped me as who i am today but it
really really gave me something to
look forward to and this excitement
that i just it i can't it's hard to put
it put it into even
into words um i get really like
emotional about it it feels like so long
ago
uh that she did that and she really just
changed my life and the people that i've
met
in that department and what did they end
up doing they all became
pretty successful and doing well for
themselves it's just
inspiring to to do that and you're right
it gives you great
you know really valuable life skills as
well to be able to
speaking for anybody social skills as
well uh
camaraderie and also to to do something
as a as a great
you know a great play for instance to
execute it on a high level
and and to do it during uil or
competition and to see
the reaction and and then you see like
this
you know 500 year old shakespearean play
come to life
this many years later and still be as
potent and it was in his day
there's something really really
incredible about that to tell you that
you can
create timeless pieces of art and and
that was exciting as well and and also
tapping into
skills that i didn't even know i had you
know which is like
you know singing theatrically i could do
that i'm like oh wow
i didn't know i could do that that's
really cool i was in my high school play
uh not the lead at all but
um uh but like there were like the cast
parties and all of that other stuff and
then like you know because you came
together you created something and then
you come together and you're
you're kind of bonded uh it's a it's a
beautiful um environment
and as an entrepreneur now it's like
that kind of thing happens
uh in business in enterprise in politics
it's like the folks who are on my team
now
uh you know like we all um went through
something special and so we're connected
i know you and the other comedians are
like super connected
because you freaking hang out on the
road and like you get out there in front
of folks i mean heck
you know you went to dubai you probably
went with a bunch of other folks i got
michelle to come with me michelle wolf
not obama but michelle wolf uh we went
out there and had a great time was her
first time there and
it was really funny you know because
people have these like projections about
going to the middle east or specifically
just talk about the emirates
and she was just being just respectful
and caring as
somebody would when you're visiting
their country right not really
judgmental is more so
i don't want to be disrespectful and uh
and
when we got there we're on the flight
there actually
she goes hey i bought a bunch of outfits
that are you know it's not like
michelle doesn't dress modestly anyway
but she was like i need to
you know i got some nice modest i got
some really conservative granny type
[ __ ]
i don't i if i was drinking water i
would have spat on her face because i
was laughing
so hard i was just like and she goes
what are you laughing at i was like just
just just wait and like the first
restaurant we went to there was like two
women sitting there with
and they were just like you know miami
you know let's just put it that way and
she just
dies laughing i'm like you feel better
you feel better now
and and it's something that she would
never wear you know so just people have
these like projections about that area
even some comedians really big comedians
they're like oh i don't know about
performing there i mean
chop my head i'm like what are you
talking about like we do all the
chopping
what are you talking about do you
understand that we're the ones that
destroyed that entire region i mean like
can we just please to acknowledge that
can we take some responsibility for that
and and they have these like projections
on on what it is and what it's like and
what they've been fed about what the
middle east is and
and it's it's just it makes me really
sad it makes me laugh and say you know
what i mean like something that makes
you laugh and cry yeah for sure yeah
it's one of those things like come on
guys
like you you stop eating this
it's not good for you this is they're
not feeding you soul food here i thought
it was fascinating that you're
i think the first arab american comedian
to perform for the troops who are
stationed in the middle east so you're
going over there be like hey guys
i was a refugee still i didn't even have
my u.s citizenship i could have just
disappeared in the middle of night
nobody would have cared
it's just like i straight i didn't have
anything any documentation i like snuck
into kuwait
to get him to go to iraq to do it and it
was the first time that i went back
because i felt like i had to reconcile a
lot in my heart about like how fast we
left and
i just thought how incredible it would
be to go perform there and it was
not necessarily was just like oh i want
to go just perform for the troops it was
more so like if i could perform in front
of them and be
myself and be really my authentic self
um then i could perform anywhere and
then i have
no uh no reservations about about doing
shows or being me
you know imagine imagine a scenario
where you're afraid to be yourself
that's how depressing is that or where a
career
coming up is like oh you're palestinian
muslim oh arab oh
oh oh why don't you just go by tony and
just be
italian like what are you talking about
you want me to erase my lineage
you know what you you know what that
suggestion is mo
that's a pro wrestling suggestion you
show up and then vince mcmahon's like
and we're going to call you
uh vinnie davichi
whatever it is this is not what i'm
doing here like
it's to me stand up comedy is the most
authentic
art form and the more personal you are
the funnier you are
and and the more you stick out and it
was just like wow i couldn't believe
this was
a regular i mean it really wore on me
for some years because people were
trying to get me to change
several people that would come out out
of nowhere and or even audience members
or
you know would just like you're so funny
maybe if you just do this you'll bust
out
you know what i mean i'm like oh you
want me to sell my soul great all right
best you want me to erase my grandmother
thank you so much i appreciate it next
you know like
thanks for the advice [ __ ] who just
had three beers i mean you you
immigrated from
um kuwait when you were nine right like
showed up here in the states and you
left
pretty quickly so going back must have
been a real
um arc because if you're nine you
remember stuff you know like you
you mean oh i remembered everything i
remember the street that we lived on i
was giving directions to the driver i
was telling them where to go and
i remembered everything i have a really
clear photographic memory for things
um and i just remember scenes and and
just like i have this
this uh this reel in my head of all the
good times the bad times and the
you know the extreme times and it was
just something that it just
it was the last time that i ever had
like a semblance of family like
real family where we're just like my
uncle's down the street my cousins are
over here
my friends are out there like you can
just walk outside and play for hours
that's a beautiful vibe
we all dream about that you like go
outside and go across the street and
then they're
they're like um you know friends or
family you just play with and like
parents don't care and just know you're
gonna be safe
yes none of that like the biggest crime
that i remember when i was there
somebody bro
and this was like front page news was
that somebody broke into
somebody's house and they stole the
jewelry from their
freezer and that was like literally
front page news
oh my god you see this you know i would
i would leave when i was
my mom was like ever since you're a kid
things like the heck like ever since you
were a little kid your ass was always
itchy you had to be out
you know you would leave i was five
years old i would leave
just walk out i've got i've got a
five-year-old eight-year-old and my
five-year-old just walked out the door
like there'd be like a super freak out
it'd be like where is he
and then my wife evelyn and i would be
like it's your fault
[Laughter]
yeah and i would be the kid i would come
back with a sandwich what were you guys
fighting about like eight hours later
like literally that's what i was my mom
would say i would you would leave
from like noon and you'd like or before
noon you would go
out you play soccer you just be gone and
you would come back like after dinner
like where have you been you know you
really miss that and you come to the
states
and you know like we're really sheltered
over there the innocence is preserved
is really preserved well one of the
things that has blown my mind about
american kids programming is there is so
much [ __ ]
warning you about strangers it is
incredible it's like
they really just try and cram that
mistrust in kind of early they're like
stranger danger
someone talks to you also
hyper-sexualized too
which is like when i first came here it
was like it was the end of fourth grade
moved to this new apartment complex
and i just met this kid like i don't
know my mom doesn't nobody knows like
what's going like
we don't know what the culture is like
fully like we there's a huge gap missing
right
and so my friend's like my dad's gone uh
we can go look at this playboy and i was
thinking like
in my head i was like oh it must be like
some toy magazine
you know playboy why not
i was like oh cool let's go check out
the play and i literally screamed when
he opened it
you know i screamed
they should definitely make a movie or
tv
show or series about your life mo and it
sounds like that might be happening not
to put pressure on you about the secret
project
so you have the comedy special on
netflix vagabond if you haven't seen it
it's on netflix you all have netflix uh
so check it out if you haven't seen it
you're working on the super secret show
um are there other things that you're
working on that you can share that
that or ways that people can check you
out uh well i'm on
i'm on the you know aside from the
vagabond of course i'm very proud of
on netflix make sure you listen through
all through the credits
uh black thought uh from the roots and
straw elliott
from the roots made that song and also
there's like some great pictures of me
performing for us troops it's just a
little bit to to get to know me a little
bit better even uh so just watch that
through i know how netflix is
i'm on uh the the hit show rami on hulu
yeah hulu freaking how did i miss that
oh my gosh yeah
uh it's it's so much fun doing that show
with the fellas uh such a fun fun show
um
and so we're doing that we're gearing up
for season three i there is a show about
my life
that's gearing up you're right andrew
it's happening i've been working really
hard
and and waiting for this opportunity for
the last 21 years so it's really
thrilling to do so and another stand-up
special
is in the works as well so uh anything
you need from me
ever we need you as the next president
united states
or at very least in that cabinet you
know
truly i truly believe in checks and
balances if you're there i truly believe
in that
thanks mo i'm gonna make you believe in
um
you know this vaccine and maybe some
other things if i get it you can just
call me and i'll let you know what's up
i'm so excited for you mo that just like
you have so much going on you're so
prolific which
like i knew some of but not all of yeah
like on every quality streamer too look
at that
it's like you know spreading it around
baby spreading around
well well please say hello to your
family and our mutual friends
um and uh yeah i really appreciate the
support and this was fun it was a
pleasure i knew it would be
it was really really a lot of fun thank
you so much for having me thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]